[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de los efectos del cob y 19
en los niños y las mujeres el planeta
vive brutales rebrotes por cuenta de la
variante delta que según la organización
mundial de la salud ya representa más de
tres cuartas partes de los nuevos casos
en muchos países y los menores de 12
años que hasta ahora salían bien
librados se están contagiando más y se
dispararon sus hospitalizaciones por
otro lado siguen sin respuesta los
múltiples reportes de mujeres que sufren
efectos en su salud menstrual por causa
del virus o de la vacunación del tema
vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez asesor científico de
france24 doctor gracias por estar
nuevamente con nosotros en nuestro
segmento en eeuu están disparados estos
casos pediátricos de kobe 19 es un casi
94.000 nuevos positivos menores de 12
años en la última semana y entre ellos
se dispararon también las
hospitalizaciones como se relaciona este
fenómeno con la variante delta
básicamente raúl lo que pasa es que como
la población vacunada la población mayor
se va desplazando el virus a la
población no inmunizada y como vemos la
población adolescente y los niños los
niños no están vacunados y la población
adolescente hasta ahora se está
vacunando entonces es el comportamiento
es que esos grupos poblacional serán más
afectados sobre todo por la alta
transmisibilidad que tiene esta variante
del cas recordemos que su área de acción
kremen está 4 ó 5 veces más que la que
conocíamos anteriormente y eso hace que
haya más tasa de contagios en esa
población que está baja mente inmunizada
doctor y entonces la vacuna para los
menores de 12 años o para cuando podría
ser porque aún no está aprobada
representa algún riesgo vacunar a
nuestros niños
no ya se ha mostrado y recientes
estudios que muestran que la vacunación
de 12 a 16 años es muy segura con
cualquiera de las vacunas rn a ahora se
están haciendo dos con formulaciones
distintas probablemente menos dosis en
población menor de 12 años y eso es lo
que se está valorando probablemente en
el próximo mes ya se someta a la
aprobación de los 6 a los 12 años y hay
otros que ya están incluso teniendo
pacientes de 1 a 6 años dentro de los
esquemas de vacunación la vacuna de
sinovac tiene una aprobación en la china
para de 3 a 17 años es decir que los
niños se pueden vacunar muy
probablemente lo van a hacer en poco
tiempo pero probablemente haya que hacer
reformulaciones de la vacuna que
necesitan ser valoradas para su
seguridad en la población hispana ahora
actor preocupa que se está dando una
infección pediátrica por coronavirus
llamada me si una infección inflamatoria
que aparece varias semanas después del
contagio con kobe 19 en eeuu ya van
cuatro mil casos y qué consiste esta
afección y como protegemos a los niños
esto no es propiamente una infección
esta es una respuesta inflamatoria
tardía que sistémica que sucede en los
niños esto está escrito desde los
principios de la pandemia en italia se
mostró muy bien cómo se era ese
comportamiento y es algo que se espera
en algunas personas pediátricas que
tiene la enfermedad no es en todos es
realmente en una población escasa y
sucede 2 a 4 semanas después de la
infección ya se han presentado casos
también en américa latina es fácil su
reconocimiento y si se instaura un
tratamiento es tratamiento es muy
efectivo y resuelve rápidamente la
enfermedad es por eso es necesario que
cuidemos a los niños porque los niños
puedan que no enfermen pero si tener
complicaciones pero tampoco debemos
preocuparnos en exageración porque esto
es algo inusual y tiene un tratamiento y
diagnóstico relativamente fácil y rap
ahora doctor pérez según la agencia
española de medicamentos del 77 por
ciento de las complicaciones registradas
tras la vacunación la vida en las
mujeres no hay estudios que determinen
por qué pasa esto y aún más angustiante
muchos de los síntomas incluyen ausencia
un periodo menstrual excesivamente
doloroso incluso con cólicos fuera del
ciclo menstrual la menstruación es un
medidor de salud porque aún no hay
estudios claro sobre esto doctor
primero tenemos que tener la
tranquilidad de que no hay ninguna
implicación ni daño en la salud de las
mujeres que han sido vacunadas se han
realizado efectos relacionados con la
una que pueden alterar el ciclo
menstrual y eso en los estudios de
farmacovigilancia se está recogiendo
pero recordemos que la menstruación es
muy sensible en las mujeres la misma
situación de confinamiento situaciones
de estrés situaciones emocionales pues
también hacen que haya desarreglos en el
periodo menstrual toda esta hora es muy
difícil establecer si son esas
situaciones o la relación con la vacuna
por eso primero las mujeres vacunarse en
toda seguridad no hay ningún estudio
contundente que afecte la salud
menstrual se y el llamado es hacerlo con
seguridad doctor gracias por su tiempo
por estar aquí con nosotros en francés
de 4 ustedes también gracias hasta aquí
5 minutos con
[Música]